hello everybody welcome to another
Python video tutorial in this video what
we're gonna be talking about is this
value error too many values to unpack
what is it what do we do to get this and
what do we do about it so the easiest
thing to show you guys is just by
example so literally I'll just call it
example and the way that you're going to
get this is when you try to unpack
variables from like a lit something like
a list in Python you also will get it
whenever you're unpacking say a numpy
array for example
same same story here so example as you
can see this example is a command it's
common delimited it's got you know if
you set example and then brackets 0
oops 0 like this it would correspond to
1 1 would be number 3 2 would be number
4 and so on
and so when you unpacked you can unpack
these values into and so instead of
saying like let's say x equals example 0
you can unpack and then like Y write
equals example 1 and so on
you can unpack the vet the values
straight into the variables really
quickly by doing something like this
where X Y a equals example and now the
problem with this though is we have four
values here and we're only specifying
two so let's go ahead and specify even 3
for example so what it's going to
attempt to do is it's going to attempt
to take all the values here and just
like store them into these variables but
the problem is it has one too many so
what you'll get when you run this is the
following write value error too many
values to unpack but if you said X Y Z a
and then you run this you won't have any
problems it's fine and then when you go
later to you know access these variables
like print X print Y Z X a and you run
that you know they're stored and so the
other time that you'll see it in what
you wouldn't want to get confused by is
for example lists within a list like
this so let's say X is
one two three four five why is three and
we're going to run off the screen so let
me just give them like three variables
in each list three five seven and then Z
na can just have one one value let's say
so you can still do this right so so
when I run this there you go you've got
you know this new list right so anyway
um that's basically basically all it is
to this whole value error too many
values unpacked basically you just tried
to unpack from some sort of variable
that had too many values corresponding
to how many variables you were feeding
it so that's pretty much all you need to
do is just add another variable figure
out what you're missing in the list so
anyways hopefully that was useful for
some of you guys as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions and until next time